la jurisdicción especial para la paz que
abre el macro caso 08 con el que
pretende investigar los crímenes
cometidos por fuerzas del estado en
asocio con otros grupos
investigará el entramado criminal en el
que miembros de la fuerza pública otro
agente del estado terceros civiles y
paramilitares se asociaron para cometer
crímenes de lesa humanidad y crímenes de
guerra contra la población civil además
indagar delitos de desaparición forzada
masacres violencia sexual y
desplazamiento los casos que abordará
son de los que aún no se han indagado en
los otros siete macro casos las líneas
de investigación corresponden a crímenes
motivados por justificaciones contra
insurgentes por el favorecimiento de
intereses económicos particulares y por
el control de la función pública en los
territorios se condensan cerca de 70 mil
estos victimizan test más de 15 mil en
principio se atribuyen a miembros de la
fuerza pública
y más de 56.000
son hechos atribuidos a paramilitares y
los restantes agentes del estado y a
terceros según la sep los investigados
ascienden a dos mil ochocientos cuarenta
pertenecientes a la fuerza pública y
agentes del estado en este macro caso se
le sumará el caso 10 que indaga sobre
delitos cometidos por la extinta
guerrilla de las farc que ocasionaron
unos 169.000 hechos victimiza antes de
ellos 54 mil víctimas de desplazamiento
forzado 50 mil 100 víctimas de uso de
medios ilícitos de guerra 48 mil
víctimas de homicidio 15 mil víctimas de
desaparición forzada y 2300 víctimas de
violencia sexual la jec centrará sus
esfuerzos de investigación en cinco
regiones donde hubo amplia influencia de
las farc principal razón por la que sus
poblaciones fueron estigmatizadas y
señaladas como colaboradoras de la
guerrilla mismo pretexto utilizado por
sus victimarios para atentar contra
ellas